and you know there's two key ingredients
i believe to a backup quarterback number
one you need to be willing to take the
pay that's being offered obviously
number two you need to be willing to
accept your spot on the depth chart not
every team wants a competitor most teams
don't want a competitor as the backup
quarterback they want somebody who is
there understanding his role is to
support and assist and get the most out
of the starter flacco willing to do that
as well and that brings us to cam newton
because every time a quarterback signs
now and i hate to compare cam newton to
colin kaepernick because it is
dramatically different circumstances but
i'm starting to detect that same vibe
that when any other quarterback signs
there is this uproar in portions of
twitter where people say well wait a
minute oh cam how how can it be that cam
newton still doesn't have a job but now
i to me this is as easy as anything to
expect yes it is explain it cam newton
would cam newton have accepted
1.5 million base
and a spot on the depth chart behind sam
darnold and a willingness to be the
backup and also absolutely not chris and
here's the other thing too even if he
would accept it the problem is he's
better than sam darnold and the players
on the team are gonna know it and
they're gonna instantly have a
controversy this is one of those that
even cam newton's mindset if you could
attach him to a lie detector test and he
would say i'll happily take 1.5 million
i'll happily be the backup i'm here to
support sam darnold the moment he goes
out on the practice field the moment he
stands next to sam darnold and you see
the physical difference between the two
guys it's over
it's over guys look at each other saying
why in the hell is 23 year old sam
darnold the quarterback of this team
don't we want to win games why isn't it
cam and i feel bad for cam he's a victim
of the fact that he's as good as he is
and that he's so clearly better than
most quarterbacks currently in the nfl
and teams right teams can't afford to
have that when they're all in with a the
guy who is their starter and they want
to see what his potential can be and can
he reach it they can't have a guy there
that's going to make more than half of
the locker room say what the hell are we
doing why isn't cam the quarterback that
that that's it mike i mean you said it
perfectly he's the opposite of joe
flacco joe flacco is willing to sit in
the back of the room and just go okay
when they want to give me a few reps
that's cool i'll give a few reps and i'm
not going to make a lot of noise and
i'll execute those reps but you know
it's not going to make anybody's jaws
drop or you know their eyes pop wide
open
cam newton he brings more to a team than
lasers and being able to run over
linebackers on the football field cam
newton has a presence in the locker room
when he walks in the locker room the
whole team's gonna go damn there's cam
newton he's he's gonna be loud and he's
got charisma and he's gonna rally people
around him and that would be the worst
thing for a team that is trying to still
mold a young quarterback to be
that what cam newton was for carolina
for the new york jets that would be
horrible it would be disaster it would
ruin sam darnold it really would and
you're right it would cause all sorts of
you know conversations in the locker
room or whatever it may be so yes cam
newton to your point mike is a victim of
his own uh greatness his own physical
ability and yeah we don't know where
he's gonna go right now he's gonna wait
it out he's certainly not gonna sign for
1.5 million to be a backup to a guy like
sam darnold there's no way that's going
to happen so it might be a while but it
has nothing to do with like
disrespecting cam newton or racism or
anything like that that's one thing i
see on social media that i just you know
i i will not partake in those thoughts
that's wrong
and there's been suggestions and reports
that he's willing to be a backup and
look first of all i don't think he
should be willing to be a backup he is
better than most of the quarterbacks
currently starting in the nfl he should
wait for his opportunity and he's a
victim of circumstance here because
teams can't bring him in for a physical
still now two months into the pandemic
you can't bring guys in for physicals to
your facility by your team doctors
hopefully we'll be at that point soon
where you can but as of now you can't so
you got to check out the foot you got to
check out the shoulder he was using a
new throwing motion last year for crying
out loud that's how bad the shoulder was
injured and surgically repaired in 2019
so that's an issue there were ankle
problems in the past you want to make
sure the guy's healthy but you know i
look at it this way
if he's willing to go in as a backup is
his mindset i'm willing to go in as a
backup because once i show up they're
going to realize i should be the starter
i mean i that that that is and because
it should be that mindset because it's
true
for most teams if you sign cam newton to
be the backup it is going to be
abundantly clear within the first two
practices that he should be the starter
and in in new york no one's going to say
whoa did you see joe flacco out there on
the practice field oh he's better than
sam darnold no one's going to say that
nothing will say in i mean i i you know
other than
green bay
other than
coming up on the list here kansas city
houston
tampa bay not that they would sign cam
newton to be tom brady's backup but
there aren't a lot of teams where
cam newton shows up and isn't the clear
number one guy regardless of what the
depth chart looks like and and teams
can't afford that even if you can afford
cam newton which you shouldn't be able
to afford cam newton because he
shouldn't settle for 1.5 or 5.5 or 7.5
he should be waiting for starter money
and i think at this point his best play
is to wait for someone to get injured
and people say oh that's more but it's
it's reality it happens look at how many
guys were injured and gone week two last
year including cam newton cam newton ben
roethlisberger drew brees now brees was
only out five weeks you know and the one
and let me ask you this chris
because if we've talked about it before
i can't remember when we did
is there a concern if you wait for cam
newton to get injured for if cam newton
waits for someone to get injured not if
you wait for cam newton to get injured
but if cam newton waits for someone to
get injured is there a concern that the
team will go next man up on the depth
chart in lieu of bringing in cam even if
he's healthy and ready to go because he
doesn't know the offense and we have a
guy who's up to speed is that yeah well
it is a concern i think the thing that
you know i think that's part of the
reason why cam
probably said that he'd be willing to
come in as a backup because he knows hey
man i haven't played a lot of football
for the last two years i've been banged
up how to deal with that of course he
did go through training camp and all
that so i think that's part of it also i
think part of the reason he's willing to
be a backup too mike is something you
said previously i think he's got the
ultimate self-confidence to where
basically other than a few teams he goes
if they sign me i'm going to show them
what i'm all about and they're going to
see that i'm better than the guy that
they got started other than about four
or five quarterbacks in the nfl you know
so he's certainly going to have that
type of confidence but yeah i think mike
to your question specifically it's going
to depend on that team and how
comfortable they are with that backup
you know if it's a backup who
uh
you know okay he's got a good grasp of
the offense but man preseason football
was shaky and i'm not sure we can trust
him you know uh to rip off a bunch of
regular season games i think then that's
when they bring in a cam newton but if
there's another situation where hey the
backup was really great during the
preseason and he's all over the offense
and knows that they might be reluctant
to do that you know so it's going to
depend on the situation going to be
intriguing and i'm still going to go
back to this mike i still think carolina
the more time that goes by the more time
i sit here and go carolina did him so
dirty they knew they were going to move
on in january
just move on let the guy release him and
let him go find a team instead he's
screwed he's in scroogeville right now
he can't do anything and i don't know
when the hell he'll sign to the football
team
if they had released him when they
released greg olson right after the
super bowl cam newton would have had a
chance to go get checked out by right
other team's doctors because it was all
pre-pandemic now he may not have been
healthy then we don't know but the
panthers were trying to
finagle trade value they wanted to to
make
something back for the cam newton
contract and it's an attractive contract
19 million for one year now he would
have wanted an extension he's probably
and he should here's the this is the
problem the guy should want to be paid
more than 20 million a year he should
expect a starting job and the
circumstances whether it's the way the
panthers handled it the pandemic his
health issues the circumstances have
conspired to make it harder for him to
get to where he needs to be but you're
right somebody is going to realize yeah
i don't feel all that good about what we
have here um maybe we should pull the
rip cord and bring in cam newton
somebody and i still i still think the
chargers should have done it they still
could do it they still should do it to
the extent they want to sell tickets
although there may be no tickets to sell
this year based on how the pandemic
plays out but i i just i feel like yeah
there are many reasons football and
business reasons to have cam newton as
your starting quarterback and i think
eventually someone's going to wake up
and realize cam newton is the direction
in which we need to go
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports